salut aujourd'hui nouveau casse-tête une
boîte à ouverture secrète inédite donc
nouvelles méthodes pour pâques et de
certains fort bah non en fait les
astuces qu'on utilise le hic elle
révolutionne le système ben moi ce que
j'aimerais c'est savoir comment résoudre
le casse-tête des 147 livres que j'ai
décidé de lire ça c'est un casse tête
pour toi bah ouais mais loïc j'ai une
solution pour toi et ça tombe bien c'est
le partenaire du jour ses couleurs je
vous en avais parlé en 2017 alors qu'on
n'était même pas en partenariat à
l'époque ces coupeurs et maintenant j'ai
une offre gratuite pour que vous
puissiez tester
est-ce que vous avez déjà imaginé dans
vos rêves les plus fous de pouvoir lire
plusieurs livres par jour et bien tu
vois de bien les assimiler et bien
maintenant c'est possible cooper c'est
une application est un site qui propose
des résumés de livres que vous pouvez le
lire ou écouter en moyenne en seulement
20 minutes ils ont un catalogue de plus
de 1500 six énormes
chaque résumé est elle à bord est
soigneusement par un expert pour
extraire le meilleur d'un livre et
ensuite vous avez aussi un lien toujours
sur le site et l'application pour vous
procurer le livre si jamais vous voulez
le lire en entier
pour moi c'est un peu matrix cette
application en gros on peut télécharger
dans ma tête plein de savoir dans tous
les domaines donc loïc et vous vous
allez apprendre des choses sur le
développement personnel sur
l'entrepreneuriat sur la culture sur les
sciences etc
ça va de l'art de la guerre de sun tzu à
commencer par le pourquoi de si nec du
coup je suis sûr que vous allez
forcément être intéressé par masse de
titres et en plus maintenant couverts
propose aussi des résumés des meilleurs
documentaires et des meilleures
conférences comme toujours le lien est
dans la description la bonne nouvelle
c'est que si vous prenez un abonnement
mensuel vous avez 30 jours gratuits au
lieu de 7 et si vous prenez un
abonnement annuel
vous avez 10 euros de réduction et 2
mois offerts comme ça vous pouvez tester
le service pour lire ou écouter tous les
titres en 20 minutes que vous étiez
promis de lire un jour et il n'y a aucun
engagement personnellement je considère
ce concept comme le futur de la
transmission de savoir j'espère que
quand vous testerez ça ça vous plaira
aussi merci encore à coubert passer
faire un tour je pense que vous allez
kiffer nous on va se prendre la tête
maintenant sur un vrai casse tête
bravo bravo d'avoir acquis certes cette
vidéo c'est un cap cas trop duré bonjour
je m'appelle fabien olicard j'aime les
casse-têtes ump casse-tête loïc ya loïc
derrière la caméra vous aimez les
casse-têtes vous dites j'aime les
casse-tête dans les commentaires si vous
aimez les casse tête je suis un peu
fatigué en ce moment je vous avoue donc
devait être un peu insupportable dans
cette vidéo mais c'est pas grave parce
que à la lecture de vos nombreux
commentaires je vois que vous êtes
précis beaucoup caucheteux des blagues
avec loïc des queues et qui en a qui
découvre qu'on fait des blagues nulles
ensemble depuis quand même des années
maintenant loïc a au moins fait avis sur
ton téléphone sa vie d'athlète a déjà
deux ou trois écrans je veux m je veux
mettre une photo de ce moment que je
vais prendre sur instagram que les gens
voient ce que je vois quand je tente des
vidéos avec toi à la ce sera sûrement
d'instagram ce soit gbagbo un peu
aujourd'hui on se fait un casse-tête
casse-tête cap a coûté très cher les
liens l'écouté 25 euros donc je pense
qu'il est produit en grande quantité si
vous en voulez un quelque part s'il ne
risquait plus cher et c'est la boîte de
l'amour un petit peu c'est la boîte
c'est bientôt la saint valentin le cud
d'attali portal portman le cui de
portman le cube de portal ah oui oui
c'est vrai que ça ressemble au type de
portable mais c'est le cube de l'amour
de portables faire attention d'ailleurs
au moule j'utilise parce que dans la
vidéo agent secret la dernière qui est
sorti donc la mission numéro une donc
deuxième vidéo agent secret c'est
durassier où on voit que vous avez ici
c'est pas moi qui ai préparé la vidéo ce
que l'équipe comme d'hab ils ont pris
une vidéo de l'ina qui fait intervenir
des gens au nom de famille un peu rigolo
et je crois que l'algorithme de youtube
a détecté que je disais des gros mots et
s'est dit on va pas trop faire voir
cette vidéo où une hypothèse numéro 2 la
vidéo vous a pas plu il faudrait pas que
je tombe dans un billet tu sais cognitif
ou on attribue ses succès à soi même et
ses échecs aux circonstances externes
on se fait ce cube difficulté tu sais
loïc
bleu nous comité des décideurs de
difficultés des cassettes l'on noté 5
sur 6 ça veut dire qu'il est compliqué
on passe en exploration tout de suite
on entend déjà des petits bruits je vais
vous les voulez faire de casse tête tu
veux couper la basse ou pied sur ton
amer
donc je teste pour l'instant les petits
cercles des petits cercles j'en ai un
cas du jeu c'est celui-là pour l'instant
qu'en encore je dis qu'il ya du jeu
c'est un jeu somme toute légère je peux
le tourner un tout petit peu comme ça
c'est pas grand chose mais je sens bien
qu'il aimerait pouvoir tourner plus dans
un sens ou dans l'autre
ici là je vois la colle on n'est pas sur
des finitions hautes autres mais
n'empêche les styles est quand même bon
a pas grand chose à dire
alors là ce que je vois ici je ne sais
pas si vous vous le verrez sur cette
caméra là mais lui un petit peu surélevé
ce cercle la papa beaucoup ont vraiment
un p2i et on sent qu'on peut le tourner
un petit peu c'est pas le cas pour les
autres et comme on n'est pas sur la
finition de dingo ce je vois même
l'encollage le voit même les points de
colle donc ça participe à me dire que
les coins ne vont pas bouger
comment ça se passe dans portal pour
réussir à ouvrir une boîte
ok c'est une pré ait un faisceau bon ok
[Musique]
j'ai pas besoin des effets spéciaux -
regarde moi c'est incroyable
maintenant la même chose vu de derrière
bon ben ça peut être le problème de ces
castes est la lacune fortes difficultés
et où il n'y a pas beaucoup de points
spécifiques c'est qu'en général il faut
que une action où deux ou trois pour les
ouvrir et c'est pas le plus simple en
fait c'est plus simple quand il ya plein
de choses à faire que quand il ya cru
une ou deux choses afin ça va se passer
avec sont attendus dans combien de temps
en temps à l'intérieur
[Musique]
en tout
il ya au moins deux ou trois trucs qui
bougent
j'arrive pas à comprendre si un chemin
ou genre à un avis rien de secret j'en
ai un qui est vers là ils se déplaceront
bon bah ouais il ce déplacement 3 au
moins trois ou quatre trucs dedans ok
ces choses là doivent m'empêcher tournée
donc si elle se trouve peut-être en
bougeant un petit peu je peux chercher à
le tourner plus ou moins voir s'il ya
des différences si si si de serre que
j'arrivais à plus le tourner ou pas je
suis pas s'il faut pas puis qu'on ne m'a
pas l'air super il est très jolie c'est
pas le problème mais comme il ya un peu
bâclé il n'a pas su l'air super super
n'a pas l'air très costaud on voit que
c'est un contreplaqué assez à ses fins
en [ __ ] j'ai l'impression d'entendre
des sons de la claque comme s'ils
savaient quelque chose mais pas du tout
non mais c'est des méthodes à moi ça
devrait illustrer cette lutte
vous avez des opérations dans votre en
france ouais ouais
jusqu'au musila le votre dos cherché à
me dire quelque chose
fritz j'écoutais vraiment voir d'où
venaient les bruits ça vient de duos de
cette surface là il ya des genres ici
pacers n'ont pas d'eau c'est quoi je me
mêle de vieil homme ah ben voilà c'est
un cube
c'est ça le truc loïc je vais rentrer
dans une accélération deux hypothèses de
thermique improbable en gros je vai
toutes examinées et je réclame que je
crois qu'en tant que jamais d'ailleurs
je réclame quoi loïc l'accélération
c'est l'observation buzz buzz
[Musique]
oui désaxé l'air on regarde je peux
tourner plus qu'avant j'ai l'impression
géré bloqués qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
juste avant c'est le moment où j'ai fait
ça comme ça
ok on avait eu un casse tête comme ça
que tu est hyper loi ouvrir que tu es
une boîte avec des espèces de picot où
les quatre ou six je me suis un pico
devait rentrer en même temps et pour les
faire entrer en fait foi les spin et la
boîte de ouf parce qu'avec là la force
de rotation et bien c'était tous poussés
en même temps alors que si tu faisais
que juste ça et genre que ceux de ce
côté là qui tombait il reste est sorti
et que je me demande c'est pas pareil je
tends et comment tu vois comme ça je
crois pas malin
merci d'avoir un peu plus j'ai pas non
parce que ça c'est le sel qui aiment la
clique qui bouge
non faut mettre un truc trop fragile
dans ta boîte quoi
alors on attend la gelée tourné à max à
droite là je le tourne à max à gauche je
dîne dans l'autre sens ça tourne
jusqu'au départ s'attendent pas
complètement complètement hélas
attendent plus donc dès que je bouge
bon le l'hypothèse est la bonne il ya
forcément des picots qui et pas parce
que une fois que je le bund on peut plus
le tourner comme ça ou alors il faut
chercher à l'ouvrir maintenant là ça se
lève un peu à quand j'appuie la regarder
juste la justice il a s quand est-ce
qu'on n'aurait pas commencer à débloquer
quelque chose donc là les deux là se
lèvent un peu la patente la sacem vient
hélas pas tant ici madame m
en fait je crois qu'on a eu attention
loïc est ce que j'entends de la musique
là que j'entame la musique ou pas le lot
mis sur moi ou miss contre moi tu es
avec moi où tu es contre moi aller les 5
sur 6 alors attends comment il
fonctionne quand ils fonctionnent donc
ça c'est bien on colle et là il ya ces
trucs là qui font ça donc là c'est le
dessous du coeur qu'on arrivait à
tourner comme ça et pourquoi la salle
bleue et là là je peux plus tout est
caché c'est à l'intérieur d'âge pour
techniquement je populaire ça c'est des
trucs qui font que ça bloque ici là avec
ça il ya un système à l'intérieur
j'arrive pas à bien comprendre mais on
fait que quand on quand on fait ça quand
spin on peut le l'ouvrir ou pas
attention en fait ça d'être que deux
choses les deux choses qui doivent
s'insérer là dedans
dans ces deux trous là c'est pour ça que
le temps que j'ai pas refermées c'est
bon très ingénieux
est-ce qu'on fait gagner voulait le
gagner dit là en commentaire loïc est ce
que tu peux devenir le premier
commentaire
oui oui ok ok on le fait gagner sur un
rasta sur ce poste là qui paraîtra dans
la journée aujourd'hui vous juste vous
lake et le poste et vous commenter ou
participer comme soit automatiquement au
tirage au sort qui sera quelques jours
plus tard vas-y je vais le refaire mais
parce que je me pose mille questions
quand même je me pose une question
c'était ou quand je m'étais laissé tu
auras d'essence fait à temps mais
pourquoi pour pessah ferme plus là je
joue même pas pourquoi ça bloque
tellement rien ne touche rien
c'est là où ici c'est moi qui étais pas
bien en beauté et là je leur ferme hélas
si je fais ça il était blanc ça c'est
pas mal mais je me dis est ce que on ne
peut pas le faire sans table genre tu
dis agen pub les jeunes vont à tu te
comment tu fais battue tu tournes et
après je passe de faire un truc styliste
il regarde pas compliqué d'ouvrir ses
ports et ce qu'ils aiment ou pas en fait
ma main je crois ne le fait pas tourner
assez vite puis mon visage crispé ça
fait pas style et dire que même si ça
marche
j'ai pas l'air si les deux fous les
coudes j'aime et je lui mets un taux de
gm est de 67% à partir maintenant je
vous notez les questeurs toute
satisfaction 67% parce que je
m'attendais quand même un truc un peu
plus compliqué comme c'est un 5 sur 6
parce qu'il y avait passé d'étape
bon en même temps je me dis en vrai
celui qui a jamais résolu de casse tête
où il faut spin et une boîte ou quoi
pour des enfants c'est des éléments se
doit être galère à la première fois que
ça nous arrive et ça a été une galère de
où j'ai passé des heures dessus
maintenant c'est devenu une option
potentiel donc ça va un peu plus
soixante-deux pour cent soixante-deux
pour cent soixante-cinq pour cent parce
que je suis avec vous 66%
parce que ça fait un moment que je
l'avais acheté que j'avais envie de
l'essayer mais je redescends à 62%
parce que le hic n'a pas fait une blague
peut-être vous faire remonter vous à 65%
donc on va seul moyenne à 63 ni c'est
validé merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
casse tête
je m'appelle toujours fabien olicard
cassette vous pouvez vous abonner en
cliquant ici ici et n'oubliez pas
d'activer la cloche c'est important on a
un gros casse-tête en prépa est ce que
vous vous souvenez de ce casse tête qui
l'a écoutée 3000 euros que je vous mets
en descriptions et je vous le mets là là
en fin de vidéo et bien sachez que ce
que j'ai promis dedans c'est en cours
c'est à dire que on a fait des op on a
eu un budget on a pu acheter ce que je
vous avais dit à la fin de cette vidéo
là
c'est en fabrication va le recevoir et
on va se faire peut-être y aura un autre
casse-tête d'ici là donc ici le
casse-tête qui valait trois mille euros
ici les cadenas est-ce que plus c'est
cher mieux ces deux c'est vous qui allez
voir ça ici c'est ma tête
ici c'est le décor ici au dessus de moi
c'est le reste de votre ordinateur ou de
votre téléphone
ici sous vos pieds c'est la terre je
suis crevé après bientôt ciao